can i just say i know the marvel end
credit scenes were always just glorified
promotions for upcoming movies but when
spider-man no way home ends with nothing
but a trailer for multiverse of madness
man i gotta say that that one just felt
a bit too salesy like i waited the whole
time through the credits needing to pee
like a racehorse because i had drank an
extra large diet coke at the very
beginning of this thing for a glorified
ad break at the end of a youtube video
yeah kind of a bummer but hey silver
lining guess it gives us more to talk
about than this hi
i'm captain america here to talk to you
about one of the most valuable traits a
soldier or student can have
patience
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show reminding you that the greatest
threat to our universe is you not
smashing that subscribe button so doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness huh
no sooner did steven strange make all
the peter parker-related problems go for
giddy bye with plot magic then
apparently the whole multiverse gets
broke to heck and this time strange has
got himself mordo problems witch
problems and even more octopus problems
plus a brand new variant of himself
showing up causing problems maybe this
sequel has had one of the most troubled
developments of any phase 4 marvel
cinematic universe movie it was one of
the first ones announced it was one of
the earliest to be delayed because of
the pandemic the original writer
director team left during pre-production
so sam raimi took over there have
apparently been multiple significant
rewrites and reshoots taking place
during the various pandemic related
delays and what's even more unusual no
one really knows what's happening with
the film itself even extremely basic
elements like which actors are appearing
in it what's it basically about have
been on a lockdown so harsh that you'd
think the literal tva were involved but
now armed with a teaser i think there's
enough in there that team theorists can
predict what's gonna happen in this
thing prior to its release in may our
track record for calling marvel stuff as
of late has been pretty solid so can we
keep our streak going ladies and
gentlemen strap in because you're about
to learn just how mad the multiverse can
get let's just start with a top line
overview of what this trailer gives us
doctor strange knows about something
that's caused havoc in the multiverse it
looks like mordo who in case you forgot
took off to go wizard hunting at the end
of the first doctor strange movie is
back to call him out on it something
unleashes a giant octopus monster that
according to a lego toy leak is meant to
be the villain gargantos and all of it
leads strange to seek out the help from
the scarlet witch before uh oh this
thing is gonna have itself a mirror
match against an evil doctor strange
variant and that's about it see in may
now if you've kept up with a smaller
screen mcu you'll know that in the
anthology series what if one of its
breakout reimagined characters was
strange supreme a dark tragic and way
overpowered multiverse variant of doctor
strange whose powers come from having
absorbed the spirits of hundreds of
demons including wouldn't you know a
giant octopus that shot one minute and
38 seconds into the teaser of a doctor
strange throwing two serpents at someone
yeah that looks a lot like one of
strange supreme's attacks from what if
so is this him and if so then what's he
doing here well first answer no i don't
think it's him by the end of what if
strange supreme is actually redeemed so
bringing him back to be evil just feels
off plus you'll notice that this strange
appears to be missing a hand maybe look
marvel likes to fake us out with
trailers like they did with thor's eye
and ragnarok so in this shot yeah looks
like he's a hand down but then here it
looks like he might just be holding it
behind his back that being said i think
there's a good chance it's gone can't
pull a fast one on me marvel i mean you
can and you have multiple times in the
past but not this time hand imagery is
everywhere around this guy which matters
considering one strange supreme had both
hands and what if and two the first
doctor strange movie was all about
steven recovering the use of his hands
after a severe injury as a result it
kind of makes it seem like this might be
a doctor strange variant that wasn't
able to recover the use of both of his
hands i'd also be remiss if i didn't
call out that sam raimi is directing
this one who ironically enough has got
himself quite a history of directing
movies where wisecracking heroes lose a
hand and then ultimately end up fighting
their evil twin
groovy are you me i'm badass and you're
good ash your goody little two shoes
good
bad i'm the guy with the gun that's the
evil dead series by the way in case you
were wondering if you're ever in need
for a horror or horror comedy check them
out but what is evil doctor strange here
for well did you happen to notice the
girl wearing the patriotic denim jacket
walking around the sanctum sanctorum at
41 seconds into the trailer that my
friends is america chavez aka miss
america how do we narrow the gap between
the rich and the poor
and she is complicated an adventurous
teenager raised by her two moms in a
women-only super-human pocket dimension
she's got superhuman strength the power
of flight and relevant to our interests
today the power to open portals and jump
across the multiverse at will not just
any portals either portals in the shape
of a star just like we see right here in
the trailer as you can imagine powers
like this make her a frequent target for
bad guys in the comics so it would make
sense that mordo or someone else would
be after that kind of power in this new
movie especially since she's young and
as a result not likely to have mastered
her skills yet enter dr strange as her
mentor and protector
yeah okay i get it i hear ya where am i
getting that america chavez is in
trouble or that strange is going to be
helping her she doesn't get named or say
anything in the trailer she doesn't even
get name dropped in international plot
summaries of the movie and yep you got
us that part is us taking a swing
strictly based on context clues that you
see in the trailer she's a younger
character in a movie otherwise full of
grown-ups we see her walking cautiously
or jumping out of harm's way strange
seems to be positioning himself in front
of her or between her in danger and
shots where they're together and you
know protecting a wayward child from
another world is kind of a standard
superhero thing to do plus given that
this is technically also a sequel to
spiderman no way home now it's easy to
picture strange feeling the need for
some personal redemption involving
teenagers in over their heads with the
multiverse so doctor strange is
protecting america's chavez from a dark
version of himself maybe but i don't
think that's quite the full case enter
wanda now since the beginning many
people including us have predicted that
she'll be some sort of villain in this
movie one division ended with her on a
big emotional downswing where are my
children her kids and her husband are
ripped away from her so she ends the
series looking through a book of dark
magic to find a way back to him she also
learns during the movie's final battle
that she's now stronger than the
sorcerer supreme no one taught me magic
your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme it's your destiny to destroy the
world which you know is just them
basically telegraphing a battle between
her and strange it would parallel her
narrative arc from the house of m comics
the movie secretly spells out the word
mom i mean there is a lot here that
we've actually gone more in depth about
in a previous episode but now in this
new trailer we have some more clues we
see wanda casting magic and this little
detail see your fingertips they're black
just like agatha harkness in the ending
battle of wandavision you see when
agatha casts evil darkhold magic her
fingers get more and more black but
wanda's fingers in that same battle
remain the same meaning that here in
doctor strange 2 where her fingers are
now black wanda is tapping into that
same evil magic that agatha was using
and now that we know that this new movie
features a girl who can rip portals
through the multiverse it seems like a
desirable skill for a grieving mother
that's looking to locate her kids that
are lost somewhere in an alternate
universe so wanda is looking to exploit
the powers of miss america to find her
kids with dr strange trying to hold her
back prompting the inevitable wizard
battle between the two that's probably
why we never see all three of them on
screen at the same time but for as
confident as i am in this prediction
there's one potential wrinkle world
events remember this sequel is coming
out six years after the original doctor
strange and in the downtime it's not
only changed its entire writing and
directing teams a few times over the
order of where it's meant to fall in the
phase 4 mcu sequence has also changed
but the biggest changes of all in this
time have come from society when in 2017
the metoo movement rocked entertainment
and politics and got people to seriously
evaluate the way women in modern media
are being portrayed including i would
expect in the mcu you might remember
that a lot of people including us were
sure that doctor strange was going to
show up at the end of juan division to
tease multiverse of madness and even
though he ultimately didn't it turns out
that at one point in time we were right
in an interview about the series with
rolling stone kevin feige himself
revealed that the crossover was cut to
avoid diminishing the strong female
character quote marvel struck a deal
with benedict cumberbatch to appear in
the final episode of the show was doctor
strange but late in the process they
wrote him out it would have taken away
from wanda which is what we didn't want
to do here's the white guy let me show
you how power works which in turn also
meant that doctor strange 2 had to be
rewritten as well as you might imagine
in a post me too world the usual wanda
house of em story of a young powerful
mother going crazy and ripping reality
apart looking for her kids rides a um a
questionable line pr wise especially
considering how twitter's always looking
for the next thing to rage tweet about
and look to the end of wanda vision
wanda as a young woman with multiverse
breaking powers that she's not fully in
control of yet no longer makes sense
with the more self-reliant empowered way
her characters define in that scenario
then it would make a lot of sense for
rewrites to make the endangered powerful
person be a younger character with
multiverse specific powers america
chavez thereby leaving wanda as um as
well honestly as anything maybe she's
helping him maybe she's still the cause
of whatever america seems to be
endangered by or maybe she's both
because again it's a multiverse but
there's still one other thing that we
need to discuss and that's leaks if you
follow marvel news you've probably heard
tons of absolutely wild stuff flying
around about this movie introductions of
other supernatural marvel mainstays like
moon knight blade and ghost rider
quicksilver coming back for real this
time rumors that patrick stewart and
hugh jackman have gone back and forth on
whether or not their respective mutant
characters would somehow cameo here even
stuff that's truly outlandish like a
variant iron man played by tom cruise
who fun fact almost had that role in a
different project from a few years
before robert downey jr in fact as
recently as november multiverse madness
underwent another significant round of
major reshoots the assumption is that
this is to add more cameos and
crossovers for legacy nostalgia
characters people who change their minds
after seeing the massively positive
reactions to spider-man no way home's
hype machine now sure half of this stuff
sounds like goofy fan fiction but here's
the thing all of it fits with one group
in the comics the illuminati the the
marvel illuminati just so we're clear
algorithm the marvel illuminati if you
know your conspiracy media you know
illuminati was the name of a secret
society from a few centuries ago that's
still popularly used as shorthand today
for scary organization behind the
curtain in marvel comics though it's the
informal name for the secret club of
team leader rich guy and political
figure superhero types we're talking the
team leader for each major marvel
faction folks like your mr fantastics
your professor x's your ironmans and
your doctor strange's their job
basically to act as the united nations
for super people to meet up behind the
scenes and share important information
with each other to keep the world stable
now that's the comics and it doesn't
quite work with movies because
everything's out in the open but instead
what if there was an illuminati of the
multiverse powerful figures who are
aware maybe the only people in their
respective timelines who are aware that
the multiverse exists and they take it
upon themselves to patch the cracks or
deal with troublemakers almost like the
tva from loki in an already packed movie
a really efficient way to make something
like this work would be to build it from
a mix of alternate versions of
characters we know like a dark version
of steven strange actors reprising their
classic roles from other movies new
faces and different roles like hey it's
iron man but he's being played by a
different guy and of course characters
who don't need any introduction in the
first place now this isn't a theory just
because it sounds cool now we get here
because it fits the rumors while also
making thematic sense for what we see in
the trailer steven strange just got done
with an adventure where his recklessness
nearly blew up the multiverse it got
someone killed it seriously altered
dozens of people's lives whether he
remembers all fragments or none of it
because of that memory wipe he has got
some serious explaining to do something
that we actually hear reflected back to
him in the trailer
so in a hypothetical scenario where
doctor strange is dealing with a teenage
girl who can portal between universes a
scarlet witch who wants to rip universes
apart to get her family back and a
multiverse illuminati who thinks all of
this is too dangerous and needs to be
eliminated sounds like suddenly we have
stephen able to apply the lessons that
he learned from spider-man he gets a
do-over of sorts all with a boatload of
cameos and callbacks while setting up a
compelling extremely human and morally
complex storyline to ground the action
in and all of that from just waiting
past the credits hold on i could have
just watched it on youtube darn it
anyway it's all just a theory a film
theory and cuts
[Music]
you